i think there's a lot of rumor and a lot
of speculation um i'm sure that there
was time for the king to have
an audience in some capacity with harry
and megan i mean don't forget that
charles is very very keen to try and
smooth relations try and move things on
but i think any speculation that she
requested a meeting is probably just
that speculation but i think we can
safely assume given that they were over
here for well over a week there would
have been time for both of them to speak
with charles i think part of the success
of queen elizabeth as we are now
realizing because i think we took it for
granted for so long
was her
ability to be head of state to be head
of the church to be the monarch whilst
also being a wife
and a mother
and a grandmother and a
great-grandmother somehow she managed to
fulfill all of those roles
[Music]
[Applause]
i think for many people one of the most
moving spectacles of the funeral was the
lone piper pipe major paul burns who was
the queen's personal piper he would wake
her up at balmoral with 15 minutes of
pipe playing outside her bedroom window
he even played when she wasn't
in residence such was his devotion to
his monarch and
i think those
haunting pipes will stay with everyone
for a very long time in fact the queen
had the pipes play at the duke of
edinburgh's funeral
and she said
for her it was one of the most moving
parts of the day it will always stay
with her she said
[Music]